eine bodenstation auf dem mond könnte so
viel schneller und einfacher realität
werden wenn sie aus material das sich
ohnehin bereits im all oder auf dem mond
selbst befindet gebaut wird gleich zwei
fliegen mit einer klappe ließen sich
damit schlagen alte satelliten
unverbrauchte raketen körper könnten für
neue raumfahrtprojekte recycelt werden
so könnte tatsächlich eine
riesenkatastrophe zudem verhindert
werden aber ist es überhaupt möglich das
material dort zu verarbeiten man kann ja
schlecht einer aluminiumfabrik auf dem
mond bauen klicks um science and future
hier gibt es einmal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
noch in diesem jahrzehnt sollen menschen
zum mond fliegen und dann auch für
längere zeit dort bleiben das große ziel
die suche nach wasser das auch für
künftige mars-mission wichtig ist denn
wasser lässt sich vom mond mit seiner
geringen schwerkraft viel leichter zum
mars bringt und im vergleich zu den
anderen himmelskörpern eignet sich der
mond als raumfahrt ziel immer noch am
besten den jupiter saturn merkur und
venus sind entweder zu weich zu heiß
oder zu weit weg der mond dagegen ist
uns am nächsten und somit relativ
einfach zu erreichen natürlich werden
transportmitteln benötigt die
astronautin astronauten sowie die fracht
kostengünstig und im großen stil in den
weltraum bringen können klar ist es geht
dabei um nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als die eroberung des weltalls dennoch
um eine bodenstation auf den mond zu
bauen wie es das artemis programm der
nasa vorsieht sind materialtransporte
von der erde notwendig und das ist nicht
nur aufwendig sondern auch sehr sehr
teuer doch es gebe eine möglichkeit
diese enormen kosten zu umgehen was wäre
wenn man einfach das material nutzen
würde das sich ohnehin schon im weltraum
oder direkt auf dem mond befindet genau
das ist die idee einiger
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
könnte also sogar eine mondstation aus
weltraumschrott gebaut werden und wie
genau ließ sie sich das realisieren
die spannenden antworten auf all diese
fragen gibt es hierbei zum science and
future fest steht diese idee würde
gleich einen weiteren vorteil mit sich
bringen und eine gefahr minimieren die
das leben auf der erde in jeder sekunde
bedroht die rede ist von den vielen
tonnen weltraumschrott die um unseren
planeten kreisen und die bedrohungslage
ist wirklich nicht zu unterschätzen denn
es sind tatsächlich jede menge vorteile
auf kollisionskurs kein wunder denn 60
jahre raumfahrt haben ihre spuren
hinterlassen
die rede ist von trümmerteilen
ausgebrannten raketenstufen defekten
satelliten und auch hinterlassenschaften
von bewusst herbeigeführte explosion
erst jüngst hat russland bei einem
militärischen spreng versucht ein
solches trümmerfeld verursacht
astronautinnen und astronauten an bord
der iss suchten schutz in den
angedockten raumschiffen um im notfall
die raumstation schnell verlassen zu
können und diese trümmer und
ausgedienten satelliten werden nicht nur
für raumfahrtmissionen sondern auch für
die infrastruktur auf unserer erde
zunehmend zur gefahr
dazu stellt der ehemalige chef der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa jan
görner folgenden vergleich an stellen
sie sich vor wie gefährlich das segeln
auf hoher see wäre wenn alle schiffe die
in der geschichte jemals verloren
gegangen sind immer noch auf dem wasser
treiben würden das ist die aktuelle
situation im orbit und es dazu nicht
weitergeben das muss man sich mal
vorstellen schätzungen zufolge könnten
mehr als
20.000 objekte mit einem durchmesser von
mindestens zehn zentimetern um unseren
planeten kreisen und zwar unkontrolliert
dazu kommen etwa
750.000 kleinere müll teilchen die ein
zentimeter groß und von der erde aus
nicht zu erkennen sind schätzungen gehen
von acht bis 9000 tonnen weltraumschrott
insgesamt aus eine wirklich bedrohliche
lage die sich in zukunft noch
verschärfen wird denn allein elenas
plant
42.000 satelliten ins all zu schießen
zudem sind auch militärprojekte von
verschiedenen staaten im alle angedacht
gefährlich wird der ganze
weltraumschrott vor allem weil er mit
einer solch hohen geschwindigkeit
unterwegs ist der astrophysiker paul
sauter geht davon aus dass die teilchen
mit einer geschwindigkeit von etwa
24.000 kilometer pro stunde unterwegs
sind und ist rückständig
kessler sind rom eine kettenreaktion
ausgelöst durch die zerstörung eines
satelliten dessen trümmerteile dann
weitere satelliten zerstören
deren trümmerteile weitere satelliten
zerstören und so weiter und so fort am
ende gibt es gar keine satelliten medien
funktionieren unsere gesamte
zivilisation wäre augenblicklich in
gefahr die kommunikation würde
zusammenbrechen internettelefon
lieferketten unterbrochen und und und
eine megakatastrophe und das ist
wirklich traurig nie man fühlt sich
verantwortlich für seinen eigenen müll
zu sorgen anders als es beispielsweise
polarexpedition der fall ist hier muss
verpflichtend alles wieder eingesammelt
werden was mitgebracht wird für den
weltraum dagegen gibt es bislang keine
verbindlichen auflagen die große frage
also wer räumt den ganzen müll auf wir
haben hier bei pixum science im future
ja schon öfter darüber berichtet welche
ideen es gibt um wieder ordnung im all
zu schaffen so beispielsweise die esa
mission teamspace man mit hilfe von vier
greifarm sollen trümmerteile im all
eingefangen werden und dann in der
erdatmosphäre verglühen bedrohliche
satelliten aktenteile und anderer müll
aus dem alt könnten dann so beseitigt
werden doch immer mehr fachleute träumen
von der idee des ortes recyclings denn
klar ist das was da über unseren köpfen
kreist ist an sich ein echter
milliardenschatz von dem die
raumfahrtindustrie profitieren können
denn alles was sich im weltraum befindet
und dorthin geschossen wurde ist alleine
wegen der extremen staat kosten
unheimlich teuer dazu kommt satelliten
beispielsweise bestehend aus wertvollen
materialien gold folien und aluminium
werden zur isolation benutzer sieht ist
auch der deutsche physiker frank koch
der orbit recycling indische tüv
gegründet hat er sagt in einem artikel
von msi technology review zu seinen
plänen in dem alte satelliten und
verbrauchte raketen körper für neue
raumfahrtprojekte recycelt werden lässt
sich nicht nur weltraumschrott
reduzieren sondern auch staat kosten in
milliardenhöhe
einstellen eine win win situation also
den aluminium lässt sich hervorragend
recyceln und die ariane-rakete
beispielsweise besteht aus rund vier
tonnen an eure und aufwendige
materialtransporte von der erde aus zum
mond beispielsweise werden also
überflüssig wenn man sich auf die
sogenannte in situ resource utilization
usa oder englisch
konzentrieren würde hierbei könnte
material genutzt werden das sich ohnehin
bereits im mai beziehungsweise auf dem
mond befindet die trümmerteile und
ausgedienten satelliten werden in einem
ersten schritt katalogisiert um so die
idealen recycling ziele im all zu
identifizieren welche materialien und
komponenten wurden verwendet und wie
bewegen sich die objekte im weltraum in
einem zweiten schritt werden die
unkontrollierten weltraum objekte dann
stabilisiert und mit der hilfe eines
greifers und schleppers zum mond
gebracht so werden bis zu vier tonnen
aluminium auf einmal zum mond
transportiert eine ganze menge im
vergleich zu einem direkt transport von
der erde aus bei dem lediglich 400
kilogramm transportiert werden können
zudem wird dabei der weltraumschrott
reduziert ebenso wie die kosten bei
einem solchen orbit recycling könnte
dann an aluminium depot auf dem mond
angelegt werden nach der geplanten
mondstation werden die schrottteile dann
an einem definierten platz zum absturz
gebracht und es muss keine riesige
aluminiumfabrik auf dem mobile baut
wenden es geht ganz einfach in tiegeln
die von sonnenkollektoren betrieben
werden werden die trümmerteile aus
diesem aluminium eingeschmolzen und für
den bau einer mondstation verwendet so
werden sogar große elemente die aufgrund
ihrer größe nicht von der erde zum mond
transportiert werden können hergestellt
beispielsweise riesige wände oder aber
dünne und zerbrechliche elemente die
einen raketenstart nicht überstehen
würden und in formen und das ist
wirklich eine genial einfache idee aus
reguliert also mondstaub werden solche
elemente dann gegossen ein
forschungsteam von der tu braunschweig
hat dazu erst tests durchgeführt hier
wurden objekte aus ariane oberstufen
aluminium und künstlichem stopp gegossen
auch die initiative ordnet recycling von
frank will sich mondstaub also reguliert
zunutze machen dazu sagt der physiker
selbst ordnet recycling hat zusammen mit
seinen partnern erste prototypen für
eine gießerei auf dem mond entwickelt
die ausschließlich reguliert und
materialien aus weltraumschrott
verwendet das daraus entstandene
verbundmaterial nennen wer rico dieses
verbundmaterial zeichnet sich durch
seine hohe wärmekapazität und
leitfähigkeit aus so könnte es
beispielsweise als konstruktionselemente
oder auch als energiespeicher eingesetzt
werden so manches ist viel einfacher als
man eben denkt denn auch ein aufzug in
den weltraum könnte auf dem mond ohne
großen aufwand gebaut werden mehr dazu
und vielen entwicklung und gefahren die
viel schneller realität werden gibt es
in meinem hoch per aufzug in den
weltraum das gibt es unter diesem link
und zwar nur dort persönlich von mir
signiert der link ist auch in der video
beschreibung und im ersten kommentaren
nur noch bis weihnachten übrigens ein
cooles geschenk also anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren also nicht hier
abonnieren aber bei e-books geht das ja
aber dann leider ohne meine signatur bis
dann bleibt haben